natalie is in San Diego hi Natalie
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hello
all right how can I help thanks for
taking my call
so me and my husband have about seventy
thousand dollars worth of debt and that
is our mortgage we will be paying that
off this year yay and we really the only
big expense we have is we do have a
one-year-old son and that we pay about
twenty thousand dollars a year for his
preschool aside from that we're going to
be completely debt-free and where we're
talking about what to do next because
we'll own our condo we will still have
the baby no car payments no student
loans we just trying to figure out what
to do with the money so one of one of
the ideas that we've been throwing
around is purchasing a property that we
would eventually retire into something
near the ocean here in San Diego and
then a couple of other friends of ours
have said you know why don't you retire
early and then kind of put more money
away so we're just in a quandary we
don't really know which way to go
actually how old are you 37 great good
job you've done beautifully
congratulations well we teach a thing
called the baby steps and you're your
child's care and your child's schooling
is not a debt it is a monthly expense
okay such as part of your budget that
doesn't even come up you have no debt
are you putting money into retirement
aggressively we are so we're both maxing
out on the Roth IRAs and then we do he
has a 403 B at work that gives him 10%
of his salary kind of like as a bonus
every year and then we contribute
probably another 10,000 to that 403 B on
tax deferred perfect very good very good
okay well then you're down to almost
what I was discussing before the break
with the other guy that you're you know
he had that five hundred thousand dollar
windfall which was awesome but you're
kind of down to the same situation
there's only three things you can do
with money you can enjoy it give it and
save it and I would like to see you
increase all three by just
managing your budget carefully it's not
like you need to be on a tight budget
where you can't enjoy life I want you to
enjoy some of this money intentionally
though what happens to people sometimes
when they finally get where you are is
they relax so much that they get sloppy
it's kind of like somebody who lost a
bunch of weight and got in shape and
then they just gave up and then they
gained on their way back don't do that
okay
instead do the thing where you just stay
on the program you stay with it you stay
with the program being being intentional
with money and just doing it on purpose
and now that means you're gonna enjoy
some money you're going to purchase some
items you're gonna go on some trips
you're gonna continue to take care of
your child in a way that is fun and
reasonable and all those kinds of things
but you're also going to probably
increase your generosity you need to be
very intentional about increasing your
generosity and then you need to invest
now I personally started where you are
about the same time you did about the
point about 20 25 years ago though and
so my net worth as a result is
ridiculous and wonderful and so I only
do two things because I discovered
wealthy people and for that matter very
wealthy people are very careful to only
invest in things they know about people
lose money when they put money and stuff
they don't know about okay so if I
decided to invest in mutual funds in my
retirement and in other things just just
buying mutual funds and I love real
estate like you mentioned and so I buy
real estate that I pay cash for one way
to do that is just put some money in
what's called a no load no Commission
sp500 fund an index fund I'll drop money
in there like crazy because there's no
Commission that Dahl goes in there and
it rides the stock market up and down
but when I get enough built up in there
I'll buy another piece of property okay
that's like my real estate savings
account kind of got it so I'm endorsing
investing so that I can invest yeah well
we're getting a little you know and we
don't want to get nervous and get sloppy
like you're talking about it you know so
I bought my condo you know a couple
years before I met my husband and it's
doubled in price and grandi a go is one
of those
nothing out of time or space so there's
there is a little bit of wonder if you
know waiting to have that cash and
paying it off in cash or with a mutual
fund investment is better than you know
buying something now at the lower price
yeah no I'm gonna if you can't pay for
it I'm not gonna put you back in debt or
that first okay you're dead free because
I find the well again I find the data
points among the wealthy is they get
debt-free and they stayed that freebie
clause your most powerful wealth
building tool is not some kind of
arbitrage game that you play with the
bank your most powerful wealth building
tool is your brains and your income and
so just stay clear be the tortoise don't
be the hare so if you want to move up in
house that you live in save up and move
up if you want to buy a piece of
property for the future that you're
gonna rent or use as a second home pay
cash for it second homes a toy okay it's
like having an extra car it's a toy and
so you always pay cash for toys if you
want to buy some investment property
that creates an income a rental property
save up and pay for it we've done all
three we have a lake house we have a
condo and we have a farm those are all
toys in addition to our home then we've
got bunches and bunches of real estate
we love real estate that makes us money
and lots and lots of tenants and that's
just so fun and it just continues to
build on itself after that and that's
what you can get to but it's a slow
steady process you're doing really good
keep it up keep it up well it's
interesting I always look for patterns
here on the air and the patterns or the
land and we don't set these calls up
what they're gonna call so always just
take it as a cue so here's the thing
I've got the only book I've written on
the wealth is called the legacy journey
all the other books I wrote were about
money not about wealth there is a
difference and these last couple calls
have been about wealth how to deal with
it when you get to baby step seven how
to deal with it when you get a lump sum
like that how to handle an unusually
high income how to deal with those kinds
of things and a good rule of thumb is
what I've been telling those last two
colors and you guys have heard at this
hour but the legacy journey covers it's
the only book I wrote by the way
it's super super super Christianized it
is completely - from a Christian
perspective and so if you're offended by
Christian things you'll completely be
offended by that book that kind of a
thing so it's called the legacy journey
we have a class called the legacy
journey that is the follow-up class to
Financial Peace University and it's not
as in-your-face but it's still a Bible
study on wealth because everybody's all
concerned about Christians having wealth
Christians having wealth and oh is that
bad would Jesus do that all this kind of
stuff the Bible is real clear about
wealth you don't own anything you just
manage it are you managing it in a
spiritually acceptable way if you're a
person of faith is a wealthy person
managing their wealth for God if it can
that be done yes it can be done you take
care of your own household first Bible
says or you're worse than an unbeliever
a good man leaves an inheritance to his
children's children that's in the Bible
David didn't build the temple Solomon
didn't use his own money to build the
temple his son the temple was
approximately 21 billion dollars in
today's dollars if you take the the
increments of biblical money and you
actually take it out to inflation
Solomon spent 21 billion dollars to
build a temple for God it was not his
money it was inherited money so what if
some of you had told David he's supposed
to give all that money away because
wealth is evil see you wouldn't have
been biblical we're just so families
managed wealth for the glory of God
families of faith - some families
mismanaged wealth and some families are
mean with their wealth and nasty that's
not what I'm talking about
but this assumption that wealth is bad
and always is horrible is not a biblical
concept and so you're managing money for
God when you do that you take care of
your own household first that's why you
can increase your spending and enjoy
some of the money for your family you
also want to invest for the future
because in the house of the wise our
stores of choice food and oil you want
to diversify because it says in a class
in cleese
he spreads your portions to 70s four to
eight for disaster may come upon the
land you want to leave an inheritance a
good man leaves an inheritance to his
children's children you want to be
outrageously generous because God loves
a cheerful Giver are you hearing the
Scriptures here that was a Bible study I
just did for you so those of you there
are people of faith calm your butt down
you're all twisted up about wealth
you're supposed to enjoy some of it give
a bunch of it invest some of it for the
future generations and so you can get
more Wow
there you go and just relax it's gonna
be okay you're gonna be all right calm
down